and for young those were equivalent in
some sense to the lost gods and so for
young your your interest was being
manipulated behind the scenes by unseen
forces that were associated with your
characterological development across
time that was the manifestation of the
self so the self is this the the
potential you let's say and the way it
operates in the present is by gripping
your interest in directing it somewhere
and that's part of the instinct of
self-realization
it's a mind-boggling idea man really
it's I think it's correct I can't see
how it can't be correct it doesn't mean
I understand it completely but it
certainly seems phenomenologically
correct and I mean the potential that
you are has to manifest itself somehow
in the here and now it has to and what
better way than by directing your
attention you know it's like it seems
like this might be useful for you or
maybe you get attracted to this person
or maybe you admire this person that
happens with kids a lot they'll admire
someone and then copy them and you can
see that that's obviously part of their
developmental progression right it's hip
form of hero-worship but kids are very
imitative and they hero-worship at the
drop of a hat and so they're they're
entranced by the the next stage of
development and if they see someone who
embodies that especially if it's in the
zone of proximal development it's it's
um it's something they could achieve
stretching a bit they find someone who
embodies that next stage of development
and then they start to imitate them and
act like them
well we're adults are no different we're
no different we're just we do it at a
perhaps more abstract and sophisticated
level